it's time to lesson plan for next week
except we only did school two days last week
so I'm really just rewriting all the things I planned last week for this week
last week was my daughter's birthday
and things just came up that I wasn't expecting
so we didn't get nearly as much done as I'd hoped for
and honestly this week is a little crazy too
with closing on our house
but we're gonna try to get some school work done
I would much rather have a plan and not execute it than not plan and wish I did
I'm going into this week with the expectation that it is going to be thrown off
but just in case it isn't
I'm red when I do my lesson plans
I plan for the perfect week
and what I mean by that is we get every subject done every day
plus all the extra activities
and honestly this very rarely ever happens
but I plan this way so I'm ready for anything
I plan for our main lesson
plus enrichment activities in case they need to go a little deeper
and extra practice in case they're kinda struggling with something
and then each day
I decide what we're gonna do based on our motivation and our attitude
because let's be honest
there are some days we just wanna get through school and move on
and then there are other days where kids are enjoying what we're doing
and they wanna do more and you never know what you're gonna get until the day of
so I plan for both scenarios
that does mean there's a lot of playing on my part
but I think it's worth it
and it's what I signed up for